what are we on are we on
I like this question the Honam and
monkey dance in the Kamiya culture is
it's very spiritual the monkey gods can
come down in rescue people you're
wishing that a God could come down and
save you from the hell that is happening
in your world right now but it also
helped to show where child's mind goes
was to escape the horror Angelina did
something beautiful with the scene that
I absolutely just loved it's one of my
favorite scene in the movie actually
really awesome
the memories when we shot scenes that
were happy memories with the complete
family that tend to bring the most
emotion out and what you missed the most
what you love the most the happiest
memories and I remember when we were
when when I was on the set and having
just one of those experience where I
looked around and I realized that
everybody on the set every single
Cambodian were affected by the genocide
and that broke my heart just to know the
collective trauma everybody myself
included were feeling it was also a
really happy redemptive healing moment
to be in because I also know I wasn't
alone
I hope I hope that people that see this
film and who are Cambodian know that
that was the reason this was made out of
my love and dedication to your country
and my belief in all that you are and
all that I hope you grow to be I'm
writing a novel and it's for the coming
out there it's about the mythology about
the app mythology it is the Kamiya
headless witch vampire queen
it's really a Walking Dead zombie
apocalypse thing when I love the way you
decide it is I've been reading it it's
very very cool matt has gone back to
Cambodia we go back very often when he's
known along his whole life and he's
knows her story and we talked about how
important it would be for Matt to work
on it because he would really be finally
not just being in his country but he
would be really doing a lot of deep
research I think for me the biggest
moment was just being on set and looking
looking at him being one of the crew and
and talking to everybody and learning
from everybody and and feeling family
as a child there were times when I
thought about giving up and I thought
you know it's just rather go to sleep
and not wake up but then I thought about
my parents and I thought about what my
mother did and to know it's a sacrifice
she did so that we could live and I
thought about what my father did and how
everything they did during the genocide
they did so that we could survive I
couldn't dishonor them
I couldn't dishonor their lives I
couldn't dishonor their work I couldn't
dishonor their spirit by giving up and
by not waking up unfortunately as an
adult and having you know lived a few
years more now I'm so grateful that I
have many more reasons to go on I've got
great friends I have a wonderful husband
life is precious and we only have this
one so now I go on because it's fun and
it's joyful and I'm really having a good
time
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you